ever hooked up with a girl and been like
embarrassed
like like after you're like i cannot
believe yeah 100 yeah yeah because she
fulfilled the need at the time but
you're looking at alpha it's one of them
ones where you know when you they say
would like when you rub one out you're
not you come back to your senses right
you're like you know what let me just
not eat it do you do you feel like a guy
doesn't know if he likes a girl until he
sleeps with her
because what do they call it
yeah i thought it was
maybe that was what it was called maybe
yeah maybe i think i
if a guy likes a girl it will show in
the immediate moments after he's just
finished yeah because if he's like oh
cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's like wanting to hold her do you
know what conversation don't you guys
don't you guys think here let's say
you're gonna you're talking to a girl
but it's not a girlfriend yeah yeah it
could be
like don't you ever think like because
this is what i think like what are we
gonna do after like and you bear in mind
you know you're gonna get there but in
your head you're like
what are you doing after that
no no no i'm saying
that i think that all the time sometimes
you're like
because sometimes they're like
that's planning
roadmap you might finish
sometimes it's not even i'm going home
sometimes it's just what the hell did i
just do interpreting like why did i just
do this
because let's say after you're done she
just starts yapping off your ear and
you're just like bro shut up
like what
what's she saying you're not even trying
to hear
savage
what's she saying your name is trying to
hear about it but listen but then again
there's a flip side because the girl
could be same type of situation but what
she's talking is what you want to hear
yeah i'm saying so in that in that
aspect then i feel like you will know if
you like to go like you know what you
just kind of like yeah yeah
and then yeah you know we'll go from
there but i think as you said straight
after
yeah i don't know
but then again i think it's it's right
before yeah it's right before because
you know if you're gonna hug the girl
after you after you have sex with or not
like you know yeah that's true if this
is a girl you wanna
that's a hug or cause some girls you
might hug and they might take it the
wrong way like
no man it's not wait they'll take it the
wrong way after you slept together
like how do you oh you're so sheltered
what
i don't get it
that's what everyone in my channel says
what do you mean please no
no i'm like so i'm like so not sheltered
like i'm like yeah i'm like aware yeah
right okay yeah but yeah what you're
saying is true
yeah
that's so weird like you you just gave
him your body
right yeah no no but like but guys like
he said nobody like that but like he
said girls want sex too
yeah right right it's true it's not just
us i feel like okay this i feel like
this is the dating market okay where am
i in bare mind what
i think girls are afraid of getting used
for their body and guys are getting
afraid of getting used for their yeah
their resources
and that's why you have these girls that
hate men and these men that hate women
because at some point they've been you
one one group has been used for their
money at some point
or their time attention whatever it is
emotional you know friend zone whatever
on the other hand these girls think that
every all these guys are super sexually
active when it's just a small percentage
it goes back to what you said about um
the truth like not a lot of people are
telling the truth when they first come
into our relationship and it's not even
just
relationships just like for normal
relationships like friendships yeah not
a lot of people didn't come in telling
the truth yeah you don't
i don't think that happens a lot so that
could be another
thing so if you're saying that like
women
are scared of being used for their body
um
a lot of women now
are just selling their body
oh yeah i know
that generally like you go to instagram
yeah they're certainly sexual but now to
be
now to say oh i'm afraid of being used
to my body it's like well what you
selling love do you know what you know
i'm so sorry let me just interject her i
saw this post on instagram saying
when you was in primary school or
secondary school the girl used to uh
that girl used to get sent nudes you
know when they go in primary school
secondary school she might have a nude
and they get sent around to everyone
right they're like
i'm pissed off because now man gotta pay
5.99
yeah
that's
men are selling their resources as well
as in what i mean they're flossing on
the internet yeah they're they're
portraying this certain lifestyle
and that attracts
women but then what you can't get
complete you can't complain if the type
of women it attracts
that's the primary reason that they came
one hundred percent so it works both
ways
if if there wasn't
then
would you not think dayton would be
because what do you think people would
actually base
dating off if the internet was nothing
they'd base it off the individual
you'd have to you've got no choice i
think i think these things would still
play a part like they did before
so a woman being attractive a man having
resources of course i think that would
still definitely play a part i think the
difference is
people were just they were way limited
in their options
before
so they would have to choose actually
one thing that um
i kind of thought about recently is that
monogamy
is a redistribution of sex
what do you mean what do you mean so
like for example okay so if you take
if you take a 10 random 10 guys and
random 10 girls and you put them on a
deserted island right you know because
of not just hypergamy but just the way
things are
more than likely what will happen is
you'll get seven or eight of those girls
will want the same two or three guys
right right okay so
if we live in a polyamorous society
right where one guy can be
involved with multiple women
let's say you get those those top three
guys at the 10 and let's say they each
have three girls each
yeah so then you have one girl who's
available and you have the seven other
guys fighting for it right which is
basically how it is right now
but then if you enforce monogamy
you force those three guys to choose one
woman
right so they're so they choose one so
they're no longer available to play with
anymore so the seven other girls they
stopped fighting for them because
they're off the market so they go back
to the other pool of men
and then everybody gets matched up
so monogamy is almost like
but those women will still want those
three guys they might but they'll choose
but they can't get them so they'll
choose someone else
[Music]
those three guys might have been their
first choice
but because they're off the market
if they want someone they're forced to
go back to the pool of men and to choose
from there
whereas if you live in a polyamorous
society which we're starting to already
you know the the cliche is you know
they'd rather share the top dog than 100
their faithfully is all to themselves
because women generally now they want a
guy who has that potential to
attract other women
yes
like you don't want some i don't think
men or women want someone that nobody
else wants no i mean there are
definitely societies where men just
cover up their women and we're like no
one else can look at this one i think
men would okay she's mine
men would like i don't i don't think men
have
uh the same
pre take the same pre-selection from
other men about a woman yeah that's true
i agree yeah yeah yeah because i
remember when i was at drama school
there was this one girl in my year that
half the guy's like oh she's amazing and
i just never saw her sorry but just
because they were all falling over her
that didn't make her more attractive to
me because i just yeah
you kind of isolate as well as i feel
like i don't know for women they may see
an average guy and not think twice but
if they see loads of girls swarming here
they're like who's that who is he yeah
yeah yeah why is he distracted yeah you
know what i mean
that's